[Música]
é eu queria começar mostrando pra vocês
uma obra de arte é ela lembra um cristal
submarino uma pintura abstrata mas na
verdade isso é uma fotografia uma
fotografia ampliada do vírus da
poliomielite
o poliovírus a poliomielite até em 1988
não possuía no mundo nenhuma ação global
para a eliminação completa do vírus em
88 tivemos 350 mil casos em 125 países
endêmicos muito pouco tempo
o ano passado o total de casos caiu pra
416 casos em apenas três países
endêmicos
isso é muito animador só que se nós não
conseguirmos nos próximos dez anos
eliminar completamente o vírus a
globalização vai fazer com que a gente
retome a 200 mil casos anuais e uma
provável pandemia bastante pior que o
ébola
mas existe um outro vírus mais perigoso
e mais letal que o da poliomielite que
ataca as grandes cidades européias assim
como as pequenas colônias de acampamento
da áfrica e da ásia
esse vírus não respeita fronteiras nem
idades e não é infantil e adulto ele é
global e total
eu falo do vírus do preconceito
o preconceito nesse exato momento ele
está contribuindo para a eliminação ou a
dificultando e tornando um inferno em
vida a vida de pessoas por conta de suas
diferentes cor da pele o quanto de suas
opções religiosas ou pelas ausências
dessas opções
o conta de suas alternativas de vida ou
escolhas sexuais por conta de sua origem
geográfica e pelos fatores mais
subjetivos e mais é incrivelmente pouco
é
é pouco é importante no trato
humanitário
o preconceito ele mesmo quando passa ele
deixa cicatrizes
quando não mata que são piores que ainda
a poliomielite
eu queria aproveitar dizem que histórias
são dados com alma eu queria contar pra
vocês um pouco da minha história pessoal
e de como eu superei os quatro
cavaleiros do apocalipse ateste a morte
a fome ea guerra que na minha cabeça
eram estavam associados a poliomielite a
paternidade à pobreza e ao preconceito
eu tive poliomielite meu primeiro
cavaleiro do apocalipse
acordei um dia com o lado direito
inteiro paralisado não enxergava não
conseguia me mover
eu tinha dez meses então meu primeiro
aniversário eu não tive primeiro
aniversário mas ganhou dois presentes
maravilhosos
um foi a minha vida e o segundo foi um
par de botas que eu usei durante alguns
anos da primeira infância e até próximo
do início da adolescência e que me
permitiram retomar essa essa vida
aparentemente normal como estou aqui
hoje é e integrar me pouco a pouco na na
sociedade e aí pra cantar escola por
exemplo
só que a escola pra mim tinha os
desafios adicionais porque você imagina
um garoto magro aqui com a cabeça grande
assim com duas botas que pareciam
nacional das alguns extraterrestre
andando na escola de forma engraçada
isso é feito ea reação dos coleguinhas
tanto na escola quanto na na vizinhança
onde morava eram imediatas então era uma
coisa muito dura
o preconceito veladamente ou não me fez
conhecer o seu pioneiro do do famoso
bolo em que agora está mapeado e
perfeitamente caracterizado não sabia o
que era isso naquela época então foram
muitos anos de fisioterapia eu
frequentei graças à intervenção e de
minha avó minha mãe e cinco dias
eu frequentei durante muitos anos centro
de fisioterapia
diariamente eu ia a presidente se
passava alguma duas horas ali depois
continue o tratamento em casa ea tive
com isso a chance de poder recuperar os
movimentos se a e as coordenações de mão
e braço ea visão e tudo mais
eu não conseguia integrar nos esportes
na escola nem na vizinhança porque era
um pouco discriminado pra futebol por
exemplo então que eu fazia restavam para
inventar nos próprios esportes não
inventava o sport com letras eu gostava
muito de jogos mentais
sempre gostei e isso contribuiu muito
para esse pra esse interesse
como não podia jogar de verdade eu fazia
um jogo é imaginário e aí jogava comigo
mesmo inventar os parceiros e tudo mais
nessa época mais ou menos no final da da
infância eu comecei a perceber que tinha
uma outra diferença comigo eu não tinha
pai a gente era uma família assim que
que não faltava um terceiro membro que
era um elemento fundamental é sempre
essa coisa da ausência paterna ou de ter
um registro três pontinhos em vez do
nome de uma pessoa continha os amigos me
incomodava isso na verdade era o meu
segundo cavaleiro do apocalipse a morte
ela levou meu pai biológico que eu nunca
conheci e meus dois padrastos que também
morreram muito precocemente
gostava bastante e me deixaram só como
herança meus queridos irmãos que que
hoje estão ainda comigo há essa relação
com a morte
ela foi também é assim ampliada por um
terceiro cavaleiros que era o cavaleiro
da fome ou a pobreza nós éramos todos de
uma família muito pobre
minha avó tinha migrado para recife
viúva muito jovem e com sete filhos
tá educar para alimentar e tudo mais
na verdade sete adolescentes minha mãe
era uma dessas adolescentes que foi mãe
solteira
17 anos e já trabalhava desde os 8 para
conseguir ajustar as contas e as coisas
em casa então eu lembro que tem alguns
algumas cenas muito marcantes assim como
por exemplo a história da do total de
mingau de cachorro é que apesar do nome
é assim tão forte era uma sopa na
verdade uma sopa de alho com água
farinha e azeite quando tinha com
margarina e que nutria muito eu achava
maravilhoso aquilo mas era uma coisa tão
traumática que era conversado em casa
assim à boca pequena e muito
positivamente para que os vizinhos não
soubessem que a gente estava numa
situação tão delicada e assim não temos
muitas opções de lazer
eu lembro que em casa a aal rádio era um
grande elemento de lazer e os livros que
chegavam por intermédio da tia mais
velha então em contato foi muito assim
era eu era nutrido à base de sopa de
alho e sopa de letras
então há um rádio e me permitiu as
primeiras experiências interessantes é
de vida eu era um menino que gostava
muito de sonhar e tinha três sonhos
recorrentes na cabeça um sonho era o
sonho de um mundo e queria conhecer o
mundo partir pra fora e é estudar e
conhecer novos idiomas morar em algum
país de preferência de língua inglesa
que aquilo sempre estava na minha na
minha cabeça e contribuirá para salvar a
humanidade trabalhar na onu alguma coisa
ligada à onu e escrever e contar
histórias
eu sempre gostei de contar histórias
então como não podia estudar inglês
porque não tinha dinheiro eu sempre fui
aluno de escola pública que podia
estudar naquilo que estava lá e aí eu
descobrir no rádio um programa que
também foi pioneiro na na educação a
distância num programa da voz da américa
nos domingos não existia globo não
existiu fantástico então eu ia pro rádio
e ficava ouvindo lá o programa da voz da
américa que ensinava inglês e se esse
programa é tão interessante que eu me
empolguei a ponto de um dia eu lembro
que uma mãe chegou no limite da
paciência dela porque eu costumava
escrever os termos em inglês na casa
há toda uma mesa europa table o chão
gravar flor escrevia literalmente
pintava aquilo lá o coloca no papel uma
coisa de louco
até que um dia ela resolveu acabar com
esse meu método paulo freire de de
aprender inglês
eu tive que fazer uma faxina geral na
casa aí mas ficaram as lições mãe era
uma pessoa e ainda é muito determinada
então ela um dia chegou pra mim mas você
gosta tanto de escrever o que você
na época ela trabalhava para um
matarazzo era uma secretária de uma das
empresas do grupo por que você não faz
uma carta para o presidente da matarazzo
francisco matarazzo sobrinho está lá em
são paulo
ora eu morava em recife no interior da
qda um subúrbio da cidade e fazer uma
carta para o presidente do grupo
matarazzo mas era minha mãe que estava
dizendo aquilo então eu sentei fez a
carta
usei de inspiração escrevi duas páginas
e contando um pouco dos meus planos de
quem estudar física ciência eo inglês me
empolguei avaí queria ir para o exterior
entreguei para a mãe ela dobrou a carta
pois na bolsa foi trabalhar
duas semanas depois mais ou menos chega
em casa de noite desse tamanhão você vai
comigo pro trabalho mas porque meu chefe
quer falar com você e aí eu fui com ela
chega lá entrevista com o diretor da
empresa aqui em recife
eu devia ter aí na época 15 para 16 anos
e aí a fiquei lá com ele isolado na sala
lá ele fez um interrogatório pareciam
entrevista para emprego e aumenta no
final ele olhou pra mim
assim que chegar e ele perguntou essa
isso aqui foi você escreveu
e eu disse sim ele aprofundou as
questões que tinha colocado na carta
disse
gostei de você eu vou fazer um parecer
positivo você vai e vou recomendar que
você recebe uma bolsa de estudos durante
o período que estiver na universidade
eu fiquei assim meio estático sair da
sala dele pisando nas nuvens
achando que aquilo era um sonho né
porque eu nunca imaginei na vida que uma
carta que escreveu e manuscrita chegou
lá no presidente volta para o cidadão
uma entrevista e tal e aquilo vira
verdade
a partir daí isso foi uma espécie de
revolução na minha cabeça eu achei que
as idéias e o propósito podem fazer com
que a vida da gente mude e de fato esse
episódio da matarazzo ele foi um
episódio muito forte
ele levou abriu muitas frentes na minha
vida eu naquele ano eu fui melhor aluna
e no ano seguinte também da escola
técnica onde estudava ganhou uma bolsa
para um curso pré-vestibular e nós não
podemos pagar
foi o segundo colocado no curso de
física e o primeiro de filosofia porque
filosofia gostava também porque tinha um
prémio de um banco na época que pagava
um cheque para o melhor primeiro
colocado e depois nos anos seguintes
seja aprovado também em engenharia
informática e aí
optei pela engenharia foi trabalhado e
engenheiro eletrônico trabalho em muitas
fábricas e no setor elétrico
algumas empresas do setor e mais aquilo
não me satisfazer alguma coisa estava
incompleta
eu tinha conseguido básico mas faltava
um sonho dos sonhos estavam lá até que
um dia eu lendo jornal no domingo de
cara com um anúncio dizendo que as
inscrições para o programa fulbright se
encerrava no dia seguinte na segunda
feira e aí me veio na cabeça o desafio
de mamãe da matarazzo karting de matar
assentam e aí eu fui o jornal que o
documento precisa e tal dia seguinte
junta tudo vai foi selecionada entre 120
países quatro candidatos do brasil
dentre eles lá estava o menino da bota
de ferro meu nome estava no meio lá o
curso de inglês pelo rádio tinha dado
certo view funciona
e aí fui para a universidade de
washington revela um período estágio em
algumas empresas americanas teve a
condição de de usufruir daquele contexto
todo foi pago pra isso
imaginem e ainda receber um diploma
assinado pelo presidente dos estados
unidos aquilo foi muito interessante
para mim
voltei para o brasil mudei de derrama ea
atividade acabei virando presidente da
empresa e e foi um período de muito
muita deslumbre eu acho a gente começa a
achar que as coisas que podem
tudo mas sempre com aquela aquele
sentimento de que não estava cumprida a
missão a coisa estava incompleta
eu não queria ser presidente da empresa
eu vim por acaso eu queria na verdade
era ir pro mundo e entrar para as nações
unidas ou trabalhar em algo do tipo e
ajudar a salvar a humanidade
até que um chega prá mim um anúncio de
de uma oportunidade no banco mundial
era um programa de intercâmbio de
conhecimento que cabia para efeito a
mente se ajustava a minha as minhas
qualificações apliquei teve o processo
seletivo alguns vídeos conferências de
entrevistas e eu fui selecionado foi
trabalhar no banco mundial 10 mil
empregados na superestrutura passei
cinco anos visitei trabalhei em vários
países na rússia na espanha os países da
américa latina na áfrica e no brasil
evidentemente e pude realizar muitas
muitos trabalhos que me remetiam aquela
época de criança pobre
o próprio slogan í o banco tinha como
lema por um mundo sem pobreza então
aquilo me fazia acordar de manhã e ele
sentia que estava fazendo a minha parte
com o banco era parte do sistema das
nações unidas e eu achei que aí estava o
segundo sonho é cumprido
e aí depois disso eu retomei após esse
projeto voltei para a minha base que era
há um setor elétrico não voltei a
trabalhar no setor elétrico e fiz um
balanço da minha vida há pouco tempo
pouco menos de dois anos eu fui olhar
para trás e ver o caminho que tinha
percorrido e aí eu avalio seguinte que
esses três cavaleiros que antes eram
apocalípticos pra mim
dos 43 eu tenha sentido fortemente
interagindo e combatido na a
poliomielite tenha ficado para trás a
pobreza já não me preocupava tanto já
não precisava mais tomar a mina ao
cachorro uma vez por semana eo terceiro
a paternidade eu também achei que tinha
ficado é resolvida na minha cabeça eu
ganhei
o apoio militar a capacidade de observar
ela me desenvolveu muito fortemente esse
lado o observador e um lado de superação
de desafios e superar desafios sempre
ficou foi uma coisa que me motivava por
dentro assim até competir comigo mesmo
agora neste mês de novembro o mês que a
cabo e eu completei 600 quilômetros de
corrida na areia eu gosto de correr na
areia descalço entre fevereiro e
novembro então isso é pouco para um
atleta mas pra mim sem botas de festa em
tênis foi uma coisa que me deixou muito
é satisfeito me dá muita a emoção
positiva à pobreza me deixou uma lição
muito grande de criatividade e inovação
a gente poder fazer mais com menos e
principalmente olhar para frente e ver
que importa muito mais pra onde você vai
do que de onde você vem
a base é comum e não importa se você
consegue alçar e lançar se acreditar em
você mesmo
essa peça
essa conjuntura de três cavaleiros que
me atormentavam constantemente ficou
completamente sanada quando eu recebi
uma uma casquinha do meu filho que dizia
o seguinte ela dizia pai
agradeço você tem você como exemplo
nunca sinta-se mal ou não ter tido um
pai pois você foi como nilton que não
tinha não tinha referências não é para
criar um cálculo fez certo da primeira
vez um carinho seu filho isso me deu
muita muita emoção e aí eu enterrei de
vez os três cavaleiros dos quatro que me
atormentava na infância apenas e
permanecia vivo que eram preconceito
eu percebi isso na hora em que fui me
despedir de de de um dos trabalhos que o
do qual eu mudava é e que nessa ocasião
eu contei um pouco da minha história
o impacto disso
tão grande em tão positivo em algumas
pessoas que eu decidi assumir a luta da
do compartilhamento e abrir as linhas
cascas de tirar estas cascas todas que
me cobriu e protegiam para encarar o
preconceito de frente e aí descobri o
seguinte que preconceito não tem vacina
mas a cura está em nossas mãos
obrigado
[Aplausos]